how are you how's your new year going so
far we're not that far into it someone
told me you have a user today some
people a lot of people do this a dry
January and say I'm gonna start else
doing that anyone nope did you swear to
do that dry January we I did and I was
doing really really good until dry Jana
returned it's like a humid January yeah
I kind of fell off the wagon and I bet
it happens gradually where you go a week
or two yeah and think I can do this and
then it's what's you know I'll have a
little bit of one glass of wine you guys
it's good for the heart yeah and then
it's like a martini later yeah right
right the weird thing is you know when
you haven't had I don't know if any of
you know this but when you haven't had
alcohol for a while look at my
judgmental face yeah and then and then
you start drinking again like weird
things happen to your body your body's
needs to react lemay yeah yes and like
weird things happen to my body in my
sleep I didn't pee the bed or anything
don't worry about that but uh I had like
the most bizarre dreams like super vivid
dreams and like the the one that just
really sticks out was I was at some
party I was having this dream that was
at a party when I was putting honey on
Jennifer Aniston's forehead because you
know celebrities only dream about of
this life yeah you had a dream where
you're putting honey on Jennifer
Aniston's forehead correct
have I ever met Jennifer Aniston no but
in this dream I had and I was putting
honey on her forehead and then she in my
dream like moved to the other side of
the room
she don't even like confront me she just
like was like I'm not gonna sit next to
you anymore because you're doing
something weird to my forehead but the
crazy thing is just last night I was at
a restaurant here in Los Angeles and she
was there right and I I almost I don't
know why is it and but I almost went up
to her to beg
I just had the weirdest dream about you
but I was like that actually might have
been a bad idea yeah yeah your security
with her security would have stopped me
you know I just had the weirdest dream
about you is something you never want to
hear no ever want to tell but yeah